yeah [ __ ] the big man's not sensitive
to certain drinking coffee and working
effectively he's always got five
substances running today oh yeah
that is crazy and i'm headed down the
highway to cocaine yeah if you say to
him hey you could die
early he'll say i expect to yes
that's what that's how you roll yeah
enjoy my company now fellas yeah when
you're a giant he figures he's a giant
and he's i'm a great dane yeah he's not
long i'm a great dane that rides hard
you rise super hard you ride hard he'll
have high blood pressure from the
nicotine yeah and the doctor's like you
got to stop and he goes no i'm not going
to and he'll finish the workout i'm
going to do six pouches in my mouth
at least go through a candidate will you
still do six he'll do whatever you want
okay yeah
because what happens is he's got to up
the ante he needs to keep chasing the
dragon no it's not even that i just
enjoy it but also i like the problem
get your brain fired up
well it's good for your cte apparently
yeah rogan to smoke cigarettes before he
goes on stage to get the nicotine i
didn't know that he smoking a cigarette
i don't know if i should have said that
out loud
uh that's that's fantastic yeah we
should probably edit that out i don't
think so okay no he doesn't give a [ __ ]
no i know the stuff he talks about he's
honest anyway about everything yeah but
he's not addicted to smoking he
literally just takes one puff sometimes
before he gets on stage whatever and
chappelle smokes on stage dude you know
i used to drink coffee between rounds do
you know how many
great books because i'm awesome
great comedy was were written uh with
using cigarettes
like cigarettes right some of the
greatest writers some of the greatest
journalists some of the greatest artists
smoked their faces off well back in the
day everybody died of [ __ ] lung
cancer you know i mean i think he had a
liver thing but he was a big smoker i
mean yeah he'd be amazed that's what
they did back in the day though
nicotine is something that keeps your
appetite down and actually it's a
stimulant yeah so it does it does
sometimes i'll do enough nicotine and
coffee i don't eat the three four in the
afternoon is that right yeah dude when i
lived in kentucky intermittent caffeine
fasting when i lived in kentucky they
still had um
smoking and non-smoking sections yeah
how many um
cigarettes i'm sorry how many cups of
coffee do you smoke um
i mean i mean i'm sorry i mean i'll
smoke it how many how many cups of
smoked coffee you drink a day or have
you cut down have you ever cut down
no
you drink it i tried i tried uh i
remember was like a thing like cut out
caffeine right that whole spiel yeah i
lasted six hours i was shaking with the
cold sweats yeah i almost died when did
you start you started early oh yeah
since a kid but uh when i uh when i wake
up my drink is uh eight shots of
espresso
that's why i start my day even the guys
well when i wake up i make the darkest
roast you've got it's like a mud sludge
like me dark down
yeah i'd say yeah maybe a little lighter
yeah maybe a little lighter not that
dark yeah but i go i go two cups at home
when i'm in my induced my kid that's
about 5 36 a.m yep and then i'll leave
the house around 8 a.m i go to starbucks
i get an 8 shot espresso
and then i come here i drink whiskey now
nicotine's in the whole time since the
moment i wake up yeah the best part is
that my boy who has the heart condition
to start a magic mind he goes you can
just take magma and i go nah my coffee
he knew i was gonna say coffee because
he used to be addicted to coffee and he
goes hey whoa he goes oh oh you can
drink your coffee too
yeah do both i do both oh imagine mine
is that little oh dude i'm going to get
us a bunch i want to see what you think
no i've had i'm [ __ ]
hard pass really yeah all set yeah you
don't like it i'll say
a little bit on it yeah yeah
yeah
i've ever done that i really believe
yeah hey why calm down have you tried it
more than this multiple times you know
he's basically vegan oh except
you're
i don't give a [ __ ] it's just like is it
a shot or is it it's like yeah a little
shot i don't care yeah yeah if it's a
shot and i actually one of those i
actually like the taste bro you know
what i mean we're talking you know what
makes you fart hard what like cough
medicine like we call it something
that's right it was that almost no i'm
positive are you that robitussin and it
is bombs over bag
really i don't know what is happening
that's keepsake
i thought you're gonna say like brussels
sprouts that's [ __ ] sex
fries don't bother me broccoli and cough
medicine oh broccoli
oh yeah broccoli broccoli forget it
so for me
i'm i'm not a medicine guy blah blah
blah
no i don't do that like steve jobs
yeah meanwhile i had a cold uh-huh and i
was just like you know what i got to
perform i took one shot of [ __ ] night
dayquil
fantastic yeah i took one shot i was
like well i'm cured a lot of sugar a lot
of sugar whatever it is i bet if you're
really sick and you need to get on stage
i take one and if you need to sleep like
night quill it will knock your ass out
now you're me groggy in the morning
you'll be groggy in the morning that's
just that just scares me though they
cool like i can handle like
yeah you possibly inducing me making me
go to sleep and [ __ ] bro there are there
bro [ __ ] sleep i be farting
i gotta worry about the [ __ ] so crazy
isn't that weird of all things i know
just [ __ ] it wow that is i don't know
and i wonder if maybe you had some
cheese or something yeah you didn't add
nuts i don't i don't eat dairy dude do
you not eat dirty at all no not at all
really why unless it's on pizza oh yeah
because you always do i don't like milk
very rarely i drink even almond milk i
don't [ __ ] with anything i'm a mouse oh
because i'm not a baby oh see i'm a
mouthful are you a baby yeah little
milk's for babies no i eat cheese i'm
using a little mouse little mouse and my
my yesterday when we were two days ago
we were doing the podcast i looked at my
phone and i got a text my girl sent me a
picture of we had this huge thing of
grated parmesan cheese oh that's nice
and it was completely empty and she goes
are you kidding me right now and
apparently
at night i i did the great choice
you take a spoon
there are other things that are a little
it's just parmesan cheese i mean there
are things that are a little more like
this
like when eating it with a spoon like
it's ice cream i got some problems take
a [ __ ] poll how many people are doing
now choose a different word because
there are other things that are more
disgusting that's not disgusting i'm
eating a mouthful of parmesan cheese
delicious it's disgusting age 24 months
that's nice i like it
huh
we like all the stinky stuff yeah yeah
yeah we're cheating
i can't believe you don't eat cheese
anymore we used to kill cheese i know i
don't
know
sometimes it's hard in your body though
you do feel dude but you like those
boards huh like now that's why now that
now that this thick elf has cavities
daddy doesn't eat sugar and daddy
doesn't do dairy you might keep your you
might keep your cavities you're not
gonna go to my dentist ah i will say
yeah dude yeah dude go around i'd say go
to your dinner to go to dennis before
yeah it starts getting deep
and then you just got problems is he
cool with me getting gold back there
though he's awesome he's lit he's also i
like him because there's no pain he's
very yeah i need that
and he's quick you know you know what i
always say about a dentist surgeon what
you want your scent dennis do you want
your surgeon especially asian no you
want him what is what is it jewish no no
i'm sorry i like where you're going i
like where you're going we like them
you want uh hair
okay okay they've done it they've done
it a long time i didn't see that now how
about this according to statistics what
when somebody's looking at your x-ray
your mri your cat scan
and looking for things do you want young
do you want old
you want young you want a young cause
you want fresh eyes you want fresh eyes
yep and that weird but when you want
somebody cutting in and you want
somebody doing the work let's get some
gray hair and some wrinkles on there's
some gray hair you've seen it all yeah
yeah they want if you're delivering a
baby do you want an old like my girl's
dog there's like 95. he's seen it all
dude so
if the baby has the umbilical cord
wrapped around his neck
he's been there
yeah he's like i got some young hot dog
i don't know if i told you this this
this ancient man he was persian he was
like like a doctor and we go in to see
if my girl's pregnant
and the [ __ ] just goes like this
he he's 90. i swear to god same thing
yeah you're talking you know and he he
just doesn't one examination puts his
fingers in and goes
i guess touches the surface and goes
yeah
you're about six weeks pregnant
what and i go about six weeks i would
say exactly if six weeks it turns out
they know everything he can just touch
yourself what a [ __ ] dude he just
said dude my doctor knew that before
anything knew the exact weight he was
like he's gonna be new spot weight
height so you gotta you gotta get the
old bones in there you don't want to get
that you don't want to use the one you
want yeah you want some tick tocker
delivering your baby yeah
for the first time my life there was we
had no we had an ob gyn for a little
while that was uh i am
we'd go in there and her hair would be
all asunder her hair would be uh
sundered her hair would be it was like
were you in a hurricane just now
did you step out you know those movies
where it's like
like marty's and they close the door
she's like
and their hair's all over yeah i i
should come in and i'd go
and then she would it's a hot mess a hot
mess and just miss [ __ ] just generally
oh she's probably doing drugs and then
go yeah well hold on that you see it's
very interesting because then i'd get go
is that what i just said last time oh
and i was like you're not even looking
at the chart i think she's so high i
think she's doing edibles i think she's
just so high all the time and i'm not
kidding so them doc's have a whole
edibles [ __ ] that doggy yeah they got
they got
real
and here's the other thing when i think
when you are doing sonograms all day and
looking at babies all day when you're
doing so i have a friend who does he's a
surgeon and he does shoulders now he's
been doing shoulders just shoulders just
shoulders all right
he's been doing just ankles when you do
that
for 30 years yeah you want to blow your
[ __ ] brains out yeah like you get so
bored with your job you get so bored
because you literally know
kind of a mechanic aren't you yeah at
this point you're a mechanic so there's
just like variations and you know you're
going to fix things sometimes but that's
what you're doing that's like you chose
this dude yeah fix my shoulder shoulders
takes my shoulder yeah
stay on the [ __ ] shoulder i didn't
choose this for you you chose this slide
i'm just saying
[ __ ] bored
i would imagine brain surgery things
that are changing all the time or not if
you're dealing with every day yeah brain
surgery probably just
well that's where you're dealing with
heavy [ __ ] yeah that's where you're
dealing with stuff that's kind of new
science we don't want to [ __ ] around
with that you know you know what i mean
i'd way rather be a guy who works with
athletes oh you got a [ __ ] neat thing
you got an ankle thing i don't want to
come out oh like just like
the surface of it yeah like you know
there's no doubt
no doubt hey where's your holiday spirit
dude yeah we all have a [ __ ] he has a
pickle rick's shirt on i have an elf hat
i'm the thick elf today not very good at
holidays here's grinch yeah put those
[ __ ] yeah
i would love to wear those
my little fur [ __ ] on my head this is
adorable oh somebody take this reindeer
out to pasture he's old
and he can't see at night
oh this reindeer is old and old but
still
no you're not a bunny
i know right yeah
hoofs dude
this guy's [ __ ] way up with this
this old reindeer
i'm out of it
this whole reindeer i think is gay
oh
oh this old reindeer little little queen
careful
and you got a little tail on the back
a little tail that just stands all up on
end you better not be hunting me
you better not be hunting
i don't like this rain dude
one won't give me a little pet of my
nose no no no i'm a reindeer nose you'd
be a retired reindeer retired i'm just
out there hate uh you manage you don't
have kids no no one else has kids the uh
elf on the shelf oh yeah yeah i know
about it love it elf on the shelf if as
a parent's exhausting you get creative
every [ __ ] night you gotta write
notes every night and then also after
chris because they're only good because
the elf they think the elves are telling
them something to do then after
christmas it's [ __ ] back to the purge
with these goddamn kids because it only
keeps them in line for december that's
right my son started crying last night
because he had a rough day he's like you
know just being a bit of a jerk and his
mom goes you know santa's not gonna
bring you a gift man you know chris was
in three days and if you keep this up
you're not getting a gift and you don't
think he downloads it he's like oh okay
but then one in the morning crying dad
dad so i wake up like what's up dude
he's like i'm not gonna get any gas
like yeah you are dude i'm gonna talk to
santa what a sweet well my son for the
first time like he he's like i don't
believe in santa and that elf uh elf on
the shelf is bs how did you feel about
that it bumped me out man because he
yeah i wonder he loved it and i even
tried i was like you don't think the elf
on the shelf is real okay
though
yeah at that age
that's when you start to figure it out i
mean tiger's all in he thinks this [ __ ]
is great
but this one i don't like giving santa
too much [ __ ] credit because
obviously dad's paying for the gifts
yeah dad tells a lot of dick jokes
before these gifts so santa and getting
all the credit yeah so he gets one gift
from santa the rest from dad yeah here's
the other book my daughter's at 13. and
when the boy has a 13 year old daughter
she spills the beans she she starts
getting them all about all kinds of
stuff you know she's already got it i'm
telling your son he's already she's
already gotten him talking about
feminist stuff and he's also like dude
what the [ __ ] yeah
she's online and she reads a lot of when
you read a lot of fantasy novels or
whatever it is there's something called
the fandom right the the people that
it's kind of like a message board well
yeah there's people that are fans that
talk about this [ __ ] and
all kinds of yeah there's all kinds of
stuff
yeah
there's all kinds of things that's cool
that's cool man listen
i wasn't a big reader as a kid either so
i but some
she's read everything yeah yeah yeah so
you read a lot now though i do read a
lot now i don't read a lot of uh but you
realize in college dude fantasy novels
all [ __ ] set how about a waste of
time
well don't say what's the big one don't
say
complete waste of time okay once you
read on history something that's going
to [ __ ] yeah you know what i actually
just hope
no hold on i haven't at least reading
though well not only that i do think
that what we don't realize how much we
get from the message of story like so
movies that you see j.r tolkien you know
when when when the hobbits shut up
shut up
reaction to world war ii it was about it
was about the nazis it was about yeah
but guess what it wasn't a wizard papa
that's a real deal daddy
some
was the idea of the all-powerful ruler
and it was all metaphor you know so you
can learn a lot from you can learn a lot
from fiction
then why don't you read them i i read
fiction i mean you can
well yeah what picture you made right
now i'm reading lord jim but but we we
all we all um we all write it up
you're not reading that at all i just
made that no you know but i mean i said
that i mean i said i love you that's
fine you don't read that stuff no
i i have trouble with fiction because
i'm trying to read a lot of non-fiction
like i'm i'm more into the history of
philosophy yeah you mean the real stuff
because you're 55 years old no no
great fiction is important
so so you and i all of us here everybody
here in this room is a product of the
stories we've heard right so think about
it any story that that that affected you
as a child
taught you the lessons the moral lessons
in life they just did right so even
harry potter right it's the idea of like
to be a man he had to go down under the
basement face the
the dragon fight the dragon and come out
you know that's fair these are all
motifs of resurrection yeah they didn't
get any of that as a kid you did you
didn't
every movie star wars whatever it might
be yeah i'm out what is it as a kid i
didn't like it yeah
my favorite movies yeah yeah i'm glad
you asked i liked uh schindler's list as
a kid
okay that was a good one but these are
very important but but those stories
have a well they're real lessons because
they're real jfk schindler's list
i mean i can go on if you want mine's
tombstone as a kid that you like
schindler's list oh yeah i watch
tombstone all the time
again tombstone is um
i'm down and out i come back you're
gonna burn in hell i'm gonna pay you
know but there's a real story it's good
there's no dragons there's no good guys
well yeah that's as old as thrones game
of thrones yes yeah but i didn't take
any learning lessons did you read the
books but you do take hell no no
no no but brennan you do take learning
lessons whether you know it or not from
great fiction teaching from game of
thrones yeah yeah i guess you walk
outside swinging a sword no i learned
not to [ __ ] my sister how about that
that's fair i learned not to trust a
small person how about that oh yeah what
the [ __ ] thank you yeah dude
what's up bro
wow that's an outrage
and then also you gotta think about some
of those movies you know braveheart you
ever read the the
you were telling the history
oh well william wallace won one small
war and then went away for eight years
and then was captured and murdered yes
it was he didn't do all these battles
it's a fun story it's like shea guevara
too it's like shea guevara if you
actually read the real story about him
in the in the mountains like he just
hunted him and killed him he was a
leader of the communist revolution yeah
i mean he looks really awesome if you
ever see what he looks like he's the guy
that got that guy oh he's a real romance
to it he was a really good looking dude
and all that but he uh he he wasn't
really
cuban right yeah he wasn't really what i
think he actually originally was from
venezuela right i can't remember but
anyway they caught him in the in the
andes they hunted him down killed him it
just didn't work out he was trying to
lead a revolution with a small band of
people and they were like hey let's
chase him into the [ __ ] mountains
yeah as the story gets going like people
want to start to really emphasize it
well it's also like
yeah it's also like pablo escobar like
if you watch like narcos you're it's
weird you're rooting for him yes but
then when you read the actual books
he's a terrorist he's an absolute
[ __ ] legit terrorist killed blown up
planes so a lot of people a lot of
people blew up supermarkets like planes
yeah so wait why do they make these like
movies and shows about it'll never be
different it'll never be different
because it's interesting because they're
anti-social because you break through
all those things they're also out you
almost root for them yeah i love pablo
i think we know them i think we root for
them for one reason they are brave or
they're recklessly brave in terms of the
fact that they are willing to do things
other people aren't they they amass
power and they take insane risks and we
all know we know how it works we all
know
we all know that's why we're obsessed
with like mafia and like criminals and
bikers
sammy the bull said that he goes you
guys want to be me like these guys who
love the mob and stuff here's what
happens you're going to kill your best
friends
he had to kill his own [ __ ]
brother-in-law you're going to kill your
your best friends you're going to you're
going to go to jail and you're going to
die it doesn't end any other way yeah
so if you want to do that go ahead but
you're going to be in solitary
confinement for six years enjoy that
[ __ ]
you know et cetera that's aggressive but
i do think that there's something about
but think about like george washington
come down cut down an apple tree yeah
you know you didn't have uh wood teeth
either huh we know this yeah yeah that's
right but think about it just learned
that think about [ __ ] uh think about
anything like that any tragedy is
basically a guy who has a flaw in their
personality
and they don't and they don't confront
it they let it it destroys them that's
like king lear that's the story of that
when you a drama is somebody who has a
flaw and then they learn how to give up
what they want for what they need yeah
and that's the lesson that's kind of a
good life lesson yeah
i didn't want i didn't see that one
dexter yeah ooh
fire fire it's a good show man oh it's
nice oh dude
this guy's got me doing the [ __ ] uh
tough mudder oh yeah you're doing the
thick mudder right thick mudder thick
mudder the fans can come out and run
with your boy chappelle's doing how far
is it it's ten miles doesn't feel what
am i doing though
but it's right it's kind of like but you
gotta run into it you're definitely not
gonna do it but um
are you saying because i can't or just
because you're schwa i know that's why i
didn't even know if you did it dude when
is it we could be in 29th
10 a.m i just got to get my my your feet
oh your feet yeah i could do it though
don't tell me i can't feel it no he
won't do it
you'll talk about doing then you won't
show up people when you're disappointed
so i'm not even
what what it's the 29th at 10am and if
you're late you can't go where is it
uh is this san bernardino
god i wish we had a computer we could
like look it up and stuff i got to start
writing huh i'm running running not
really like because
i didn't like prepare for no it's like
it's like jog stop complete an obstacle
jog stop
i can't believe that first of all that
picture i've never done anything like
that i'd like to do it yeah where's it
at
says los angeles
elsinore
where is that gin
i can't believe i'm doing this
hey take it easy it's not that insane
brian do it too i think i'm going to
with you guys yeah yeah
is that like orange county yeah that's
down south orange county
so you just go down there and you see
that looks pretty far actually so let's
see they don't sleep down there what do
you [ __ ] psycho you take a [ __ ]
you just wake up at like 7 00 a.m and
drive down there yeah you just go down
there and
it's like a leg hill
two hours already six minutes that's
right now though well that's look at all
the traffic on saturday morning at 7 00
a.m yeah i better get there hour 30. how
many miles is this 98 miles okay
oh wait no that's
down
yeah about hour and a half
uh 98 miles yeah 98 miles 500 miles an
hour at least 98 yeah but that's a two
and a half no matter how you cut it
that's two and a half that's from
calabasas no matter how you cut that
boat were you from brian i mean i i live
down in mountain beach manhattan so cut
maybe for me 45 minutes yeah him yeah
i'll be good
brian's closer uh i'll oh that's not bad
no 75 miles i'll stay down that's hour
20. i'll go down there that night and
i'll stay there you're not doing it but
whatever oh yeah get some sleep get a
nice good rest all right i'm going to
say i'll do that people think it's
tougher don't be surprised oh it's the
29th though january 20th yeah yeah i'm
around don't you have to sign up now
it's selling dude and it could be a
birthday thing for us like you're the
23rd 23rd or 26th yeah we can make it
like a bird like turn to 35 and turn it
50. then you get done and they have like
food trucks out there whiskey it's fun
i'll do it with you look at that
i'll do it you me mark harley a bunch of
thick boys out there i don't want to get
shocked do i have to get electrocuted
100
that hurts it did hurt but uh they told
me i moved too slow like you got to move
faster through it
like no matter what it is like even like
in the water you just gotta blaze
through it when you sit there is when it
really hits your heart really like when
i ran through when you got to run
through it wasn't a big deal
brian he said we got to climb like a big
wall and [ __ ] though
maybe i can do all that [ __ ] that's the
toughest part does that see is that hard
i saw some kid blow his [ __ ] knee out
what the [ __ ] is he trying to do climb
the wall spell
but he like you know i mean climbing the
wall
how was he trying to climb i don't want
to get muddy though all right is that
cool this isn't for you brian so if you
don't get shocked you only get wet you
don't get muddy you don't want to run
maybe the tough mudder is not for you
yeah but i kind of want to do it too
though that's not for you dude you don't
think so
uh keep scrolling down chin
i mean most people younger than me in it
yeah no there's all sorts of people
beer
so choose your event yes saturday 29th
how far is it it's 10 miles 15k 15k
we got this
yeah we do yeah
again it's not like you're not running
for 15 minutes [ __ ] straight
i'll i'm gonna do it with you i've
always wanted to do it yeah there's so
it's so fun dude yeah we'll have a blast
i gotta get some special shoes we all
talk about it'll be fun yeah it'll be
fun it's so much fun it's like a team
thing i'm doing it yeah you're doing it
yeah because you're not you're talking
like we're not trying to like there's
actual professionals they're like
setting records
but then you know we finished like
we were talking about that like i
watched uh river runner [ __ ] dude
the only reason i watched it was like
these these white water rafters same
thing as the climbers right people die
all the time guys like oh four of my
friends drowned hmm okay well that's
fine um and he was all bunched up about
it they're all i get it that you're
bunched up there it is meanwhile they go
down the [ __ ] they go down beyond
paddling wait where'd they go they're in
water they go it's white water rafting
they go in africa things get dicey so
don't see how small that is yeah they go
in africa down these insane rapids some
of the worst in the world
and then when you land in the still
water
it is the area of crocodiles well there
are more crocodiles than hippos than
anywhere else
so why the world
and anywhere else go look at this little
sardine go to the go to the trailer and
let me show it's just go to the trailer
and take a look at what i'm saying i'll
tell you with stuff like like the guy
climbing all the mountains the river
thing all i need to see is the trailer
look at me to the right look at that big
boy now watch him watch please watch
look at that boy he's watching him get
it man get out of here you got to start
from somewhere
11 million views but watch watch um look
at him do me a favor and watch this and
tell me how this makes sense
like
you [ __ ] up
just the white one but let's add
crocodiles and like i don't understand
why standing on top of a rabbit
you still know that even though you've
done all of this that is insane to me
that one moment well people die all the
time
yeah
like all the time
and you don't see that
that's part of what it looks like
today did you say
is this guy okay
it seems he's a mental illness well he
got he got it
i think great
oh he did it
he couldn't figure out one of those
levels forever his teeth are cool they
have an inner fire why is everyone so
well so as their friends
apparently apparently one of the things
you got to be to be a kayaker is ugly
something well guy kaiken's been [ __ ]
tough on him
moment that's his girl his mom his mom
two kayaking
physically healing yeah i was mentally
[ __ ] up meditate white white
kids to get me back oh why polish
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] kidding hard pass
you you watch this
yeah that's not the one i wanted you oh
god don't make me watch another one
that's it quick that's it
that's the trailer bro that's it i can't
believe you said wow this is
that was the trailer bro from netflix no
i just want you to see no that looks
good i want you to see where it's like
two seconds where do they show the crocs
go just find the one just keep going
down is this the 58 second one right
here yeah it's probably the shortest
[ __ ] one
it's the short one
just tell me which one i'll just do
oh god talk amongst yourselves talk
amongst yourselves talk amongst
yourselves
my name is krista wiles i don't know if
this was
no this is
no [ __ ] this one [ __ ] this go back to
the other one go back to the other go
there we
we're the crocodiles i don't know let's
see this one oh wait hold on hey do you
think you made that up no
because you don't think they're throwing
crocodiles and hippos in the first
trailer
wait
if we're gonna do this we to be all in
are you [ __ ] kidding me
no that's the same trailer but cut
anyway
they go in africa and no they don't
where they're still no he's in india bro
huh yeah this is this one talks about
him doing four rivers in india
no i know bubba but
they did a thing where they're like if
you fall over
if you fall over you're in some you're
in some real do you think they're making
that up for the cameras they're official
the river runner crocodiles
i don't see any kayak or necks or cracks
oh man they go into those waters with
these [ __ ] things they died that
would have been on the trailer
it is on the trailer
we just watched it
chin's fault he could never find it
which has the most crosstalk no don't
worry about that i'm just trying to find
out there's a [ __ ] that one the
official trailer is the one
which river has the one that we just
watched from just that one is that the
moment
again let's watch it again
let's watch it these these [ __ ] you
like that stuff yeah climbing mountains
going out wait did you watch that dock
yeah you watched that boat the minute i
saw the crocodiles i had to watch that
part i was like you get in the water
crocodiles my biggest fear yeah and and
and do you think they got into it hippos
do you think they actually rode with
crocodiles do you think i see them in
that water
but did you see the man next to
crocodile that's not true yes nope they
showed crocodile you know what it is
like naked afraid where they're like
this land has lions and crocodiles and
you know what happens i'm naked afraid
no one ever runs into a crocodiles or
lions and that's what happened here they
showed up you see him like this just get
footage and you see this huge crocodile
like yeah like what the [ __ ] no they're
like i'm sure they're like they're
we've seen crocodiles in this river
before find it try my best bro it shows
a little crocodile eyes up out of the
water no they're you like you've never
seen everywhere they're [ __ ]
everywhere they're never close to those
animals
those animals are terrified terrifying
dude yeah they're
that they're
they're
just talking about their story i can't
believe this [ __ ] is on one thing about
kayaking when we get done we get [ __ ]
up all right oh by the way
though so anybody who does that the
extremists like that the guys who climb
the mountains and stuff and they drink a
beer up there well that's that's called
an addictive personality so they almost
always have a history of drinking
substance abuse there's they're they
won't do one type of acid they do all
the acid don't they get don't you get
like drunk like easier when you go up
that that high what's that
that elevation well they're not high are
they they're they're at sea level no i
thought you were talking about the uh
hikers
yeah i guess you smoke weed on top of
everest you get pretty [ __ ] high this
is uh this is not your guy
there it is i told you they're
they're getting attacked by a crocodile
all right nobody's gonna attack that's
actually scary yeah why did you see what
they're doing now so dum-dums so you
guys are on your kayaks and you're
wondering why now
though oh [ __ ] oh
while they're coming after them is what
they're doing kind of all right it's
okay well that's all good dude
that was a big cut
[ __ ] god that's it
little boat in costa rica and i was all
up on that crop you were giving it a
little pet oh yeah you let your fingers
drag across it really hanging off he was
like he was the size of this room yeah
it was a diamond it was a dinosaur
hanging like that 20 it was they called
him osama bin laden 23 feet long he's so
big
he lets his hand just go
and i was like dude that thing can turn
around he looked tired though he's just
laughing
they feed him yeah oh if he decided we'd
be rob and roll yeah a little shitty
boat too no you got to get your legs
around his body and just go with it
with it you roll with them is that what
you do
there's that woman who did that with the
alligator she got oh yeah the in the uh
yeah we watched on here yeah yeah
yeah but that's a 23 footer that'll do
it
you watch that whole dock on that guy
going down the river
yeah and the [ __ ] crocs
what a waste of time did you brian
yeah you [ __ ]
and also
you i hate that i have the
drake thing i told you about with kanye
yeah you were right
you're right yeah they took them out
you're right because the the rights
but to be honest with you to be really
honest with you i watched the whole
thing and that
that particular section didn't show them
with crosstalk that that section was
very short oh it was
kind of just breezed through that i
don't understand how you get in african
rivers with a tiny boat like that with
those giant crocs
i don't get it
i don't get watching a documentary on
kayaking i'll be honest
hard pass dude yeah i fast forward to it
the crocodile party yeah
when you roll over
you got to roll yourself back up buddy
on the kayak that's right because what
happens sometimes is when a croc attacks
you like
so there have been
there have been with kayakers there's
been seven attacks
of all time seven attacks of all time
how many kayakers have been attacked by
crocodiles
one there we go it's at one million one
hundred thousand this year
how many kayakers get
is there one kayak in here
yeah anyone uh kayaking do you have kyle
i'm not anything crazy like that but i
have gone on kayaking adventures with
some pabst blue ribbon but nothing like
that yeah i have no go oh it's a little
crocodile attack jen your tailbone
terrible at researching the crocodiles
that we're not trying to find that up
yeah
yeah they do dude here's good attacks
they're not allocated hey they're all
right well that says what are the odds
getting attacked by not allocators
probably crocodiles there's a big
difference a huge difference yeah
alligators are america dude yeah
alligators
yes it does happen
not something we can say for sure
no matter how much we wish it were so
that's that's alligators guys no that's
crocodiles
alligators
alligators 24 7 attack 24. bam bam bam
bam can't attack people from boats oof
okay
[Music]
yeah that's not fun well there's that
guy paddle boarding it's just that giant
great white underneath them
yeah didn't do anything what
that's fine if it doesn't look like
that's like out in marina though right
dude and i've also talked to people i
grew up in africa and she said oh have
you she goes yeah
from kenya oh you're like hey
you ever been attacked by a crocodile
you know what she said
the minute you're in that water and she
goes she goes she's from kenya and she
goes that's not true i go what
crocodiles attacks they come right at
you they come right for you and she goes
she just looked at me and she's scared i
don't think that's true i've never had
that experience she's been around a long
time
but don't [ __ ] around this guy was
pulled away from
yeah oh
we found one henry cozy living in uganda
i told you so congo totally yeah tuesday
morning attacking don't go down the
condo and even then they said the reason
is because a lot of their food has been
taken has not been recovered so now
they're coming after humans but they
used to never be there the body oh oh
wow you know not super rare man
yeah
and they will run away from you a lot of
times yeah they're terrifying unless
you're in the water and you're like
splashing around yeah
also don't kayak though you know don't
kayak yeah there's other ways to get
your rocks don't kayak they had in this
thing they had them dragging their kayak
up a mountain in the snow
i was like oh cool just to get to the
top to get to the corner just to get to
the gorge
i can't believe you watched that drop in
[ __ ] is [ __ ] crazy yeah 12 000 foot
walls on either side of you
no thanks yeah
no i'm not into it life is too short to
climb mountains without ropes and too
short to climb to the top of very tall
mountains where you need oxygen and life
is also too short to kayak in white
water like similar lines don't have kids
they don't they're usually young people
they're young extreme people it's
exactly like the young people yeah
you don't have like kids and stuff
because you're not [ __ ] planning a
trip in everest because you're there for
eight months well it's like some of
these it's some people just have this
need to do something dangerous i guess
it's how they get the juices like those
people on that show alone i gotta start
getting my athletic greens everybody i
know seems to have crazy energy tell me
about it i love it they do it every
morning it's delicious it is so
fantastic it's so easy i put in eight
ounces of water it tastes fantastic
basically a multivitamin all right ag-1
by athletic greens by athletic vitamins
minerals whole food sourced ingredients
got a multivitamin multi mineral
probiotic greens superfood blend and
more in
all in one daily serving health
digestion support healthy immune systems
all right it's delicious as well be
healthy man be like your favorite
podcasters athletes moms dads rookies
comics whatever it is
they use ag-1 and make it easy athletic
greens is going to give you immune
supporting free one-year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase if you visit
athleticgreens.com fighter again simply
visit athletic greens.com fighter to
take control of your health and give a g
one a try but you know what the best
gift you can give somebody well health
health optimized supplements optimized
nutrition great workout gear we're
talking about audit.com jingle jingle
jingle bell
focus dude how about improve your mood
how about improve your digestive health
how about improve just generally dude
you tried the new alpha brain black
label you're trying to step your game up
or alpha brain focus shot black label
dude daddy use it before he does any
comedy any podcast i'm on that focus
shot dude they got great protein
creatine glutamine we got coffee for
your thick asses also don't wait for
january 1 to get in shape start right
now give the gift of health we're
talking about kettlebells on it demand
workouts bags all kinds of battle ropes
sandbags dude home fitness programs you
don't have to go to the gym if you're
scared to leave the house on at 6
streaming fitness whatever you're trying
to barbell body weight durability
give the gift of health on it dot com
slash fighter ten percent off merry
christmas that's how they get the juices
like those people on that show alone
when they go out is it though
is that middle class
but again he won that show do you think
they do you think they put that moose
there that show so boring oh yeah i saw
watching naked afraid because they had
like pythons with nyquil they're like oh
my god
when rogan and i they dropped us off on
a glacial lake in canada i mean alaska
around the middle of [ __ ] nowhere and
it was so miserable that even the
animals we get up there and the guy goes
i mean the animals aren't going to be up
here i go what they're cold
it's just too miserable they go down to
the lowlands and i was like oh so we'll
just spend five days up here we didn't
see anything nothing did you guys not
catch anything that day you're cold the
whole time you're cold and wet the whole
time
there you go
look at that face
look at that
that's an intense face dude it's cold
huh uh
wet you're wet all the time and cold
yeah
you don't look right for that life
joey's shaking joe's shaking his lips
were [ __ ] and his lips were going
yeah he had these giant lips there right
that died he was like
you just always called uh
it was fun though right
all we do is laugh all i did was make
joe laugh and who's that guy with you
he's like
the greatest
he's like
he's like the michael jordan that
[ __ ] can find you food anywhere
anytime he can find you he can look at
tracks and go out to beaver he can smell
he's you smell that i go
and it smelled weird i go that's beaver
i was like damn how the [ __ ]
piece of fat from behind the eyeball of
a deer that joe shot and sucked it and
he goes put that in your mouth
it really sucks and it was a piece of
towel you sucked eyeball i chewed it it
wasn't an eyeball it was the fat behind
the fat behind it it's like a chew it's
like a piece of gum there's nothing on
it it's just like a piece of gum like
that's really dry so what does it do for
you does it give you like because this
is a weird thing people used to chew
these like native americans like it was
like chewing gum you just
yeah but didn't gun gum start from the
hoofs of horses i believe so pretty sure
i believe so this one's okay we should
make this more
put sugar in it yeah yeah and make it
pink i like [ __ ] sugar
is that a young [ __ ] nati as well
that was a good show too bro oh yeah not
bad right
yeah i i [ __ ] uh
oh that's a lot of views it's a lot of
views almost no
media there's a big show yeah a future
yeah i had i actually i think i passed
pretty i did pretty well on this
outdoor test you didn't die no because i
watch a lot of youtube on it i wat i i
like
studied it before you went in i just
liked it
and all that huh you didn't catch
anything
no no that's what it's like that'd be so
difficult it always rains all the time
yeah there you go
yeah all the time all the time all the
time and how did they decide to fly you
guys up to
uh where alaska yep and i said and that
guy dan know he goes he goes we're going
to be sleeping in water and i go let's
not do that is there any way we can not
do that and then
i'm like bear grylls yeah shoot me in
the wilderness when the camera shut off
flying me to the fourth
i'm the same way but also but also staff
have sneakers in your body when you're
up there in the middle of nowhere you
gotta you come out with a seaplane and
if you don't get out there in time
you have to wait till the next weather
window now alaska can decide you know
what guys
winner came early this year
hell no how long were you guys out there
being i don't know
five years and it felt like a long time
this was montana that's where i've never
been that cold
the other place looked a lot colder
you'd be fun what are you guys shooting
over there did you guys kill anything in
montana yeah i caught i got myself a
deer you did got yourself a buck this is
where i pulled quills out of his ass and
his legs
out of rogans yep
he dove off this thing got panicked and
tried to chase the deer and rogan caught
that i ate that deer raw
you hit it wrong yeah did you
it's delicious you gotta just call it
dress in it chappelle yeah that's the
thing in the field that's the hardest
yeah man yeah i'm all set
i think that's pretty cool man honestly
yeah i'd like to do it once it's not the
killing of the deer it's the it's the
fun it's where to get just being out
there i'm all set on the killing you do
[ __ ] together yeah but tough matters two
hours yeah but there's something about
being cold and miserable because you
laugh your ass yeah with your buddies
yeah
yeah last tough mudder me mark just
talked the whole time yeah just like
doing a podcast for two hours it's great
and people are helping you up and it's
great you get done they have these
delicious hot dogs it's great yeah i'm
actually excited it'll be fun yeah yeah
are you gonna train for it are you just
gonna go
you're gonna train me for it
yeah you got my bag you got me i got you
buddy you look like you got me i got you
man you just [ __ ] yeah also it's not
just like these crazy fit people that do
it so if you're
you know shy about signing up for it
it's really
there's all sorts of body types out
there you feel me oh really yeah what
shoes should i think of
what shoes just good running shoes
you can get muddy you know and then
think of like hiking too so like a good
like we got a hike a hike a hiking shoe
like a hiking run and shoot like those
hokas are really good for it bring that
up hocus pocus are dope they're like uh
a tough train like running shoe
h-o-k gucci boots
no these
you yeah like those really yeah really
especially for your feet great support
the best shoes you can wear for your
feet oh is that right yeah so those are
they're real cushiony though yep well
not those those are weird at the back
yeah real weird
hocus pocus yeah that's a real thick
sole then yeah those are what like guys
who run like uh iron man oh i didn't
know that those are like the more common
ones oh really all right
those are like the prettiest of the
hocus you want like the right now should
i have insults or just go with whatever
i usually should get those all black
ones dude whatever you want to do well i
got my feet issue yeah so put your
insoles in those things you'll be all
set promise you won't have any issues
okay i would order him now though what
happened to your feet
he's fifty-five trebel
never mind this no my feet are rebelling
against me well i'm dying from that's
how you start dying
your head looks like your head and your
feet start to die yeah
all right fair enough
yeah we get you some hocus yeah
i run the tough mudder shoes the game
some shoes are pretty good yeah but i
have some hoe cause i've ran out oh look
i got those on clouds well on clouds are
good right
you know what though they they collect
dirt they collect mud
oh those shoes right there yeah those
looks like that hocus have good um
traction that's why you want to track
you want traction because if it's like
because it's a different trail than i
ran but i assume it's the same okay
well
that should be good then we'll have some
uh thick mudder official shirts say team
thick on the back
great i'm thinking maybe wear some cut
short shorts
that you're not taking out the front for
that should i wear shorts
i did
with tights what's better
what all the what the buttery boys wear
we all wore shorts i might wear the
shorts with tights i don't know why my
ass pulls down gonna get wet dude it's
gonna be soaking wet tights yeah
you're wet like i'm talking like up to
your chest and water my ass pulls shorts
down and pulls my shorts down hey dude
i'm gonna wear uh i know what to do you
got this
i wouldn't wear like a big jacket or
nothing like that yeah no
because
we got hot it gets cold at first and
then you just not really it was fine
yeah you might be a little chilly in the
morning you know it's [ __ ] la you
know you'll be all right figure it out i
[ __ ] like runs a polo figure it out
anti-chaff cream
oh that [ __ ] i'll do it i did start
cramping at the end though i'm not gonna
lie to you yeah after ten miles that's
your boy's cramping i got it trail shoes
i didn't eat anything before
something something some fan gave me a
beer right as i was about to start like
gloves nah that's all [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
gloves scream sunscreen you don't need
sunscreen yeah positive attitude i need
that out of you though hey you nobody
complained the whole time i don't
complain i'm tough all right i'm not i i
doubt you would complain no i'm tough
i'm yeah i'm way tougher than most
people oh yeah no yeah
yeah brian stuff i don't know
you'll finish it for sure now you'll be
running with me and
mark and then we'll be like helping
chappelle up and stuff hey no i'm just
saying like you don't have to worry
about getting left behind yeah no man
why are you just assuming you're the one
left behind man left behind no man left
behind why would you assume that when
was the last time you ran oh one last
time he's allergic to cardio
can you how many well no he hikes though
you hike yeah have you ever just have
you ever tried to do just 20 burpees in
a row
yeah chipper could do that we did it the
other day i'm just curious he's done
that yeah okay so you're in shape yeah i
think i could do it i think todd
feldman's gonna do it with this oh great
yeah
todd's gonna do it there's me a bunch of
thick boys out there todd's not a thick
boy todd's a small guy so he's small
should be able to run he didn't have any
surgery he's in super shape todd's super
[ __ ] he had knee surgery like a year ago
but he should be all right
but again it's you're not i don't want
people to think oh we're all sprinting
10 miles
it's like jog walk
obstacle jog walk obstacle junk but also
so you have your dog somewhat yeah but
you're like
you know we're trying to set any records
you're like a team so me and mark are
helping each other up in the water
all right it'll be great all right we
gotta do adderall if you want wait what
what'd you say no no no who said no
because i heard no i i heard that they
were illegal and i said gel packs okay
uh you know what i thought you said
that's so stupid i thought you said
adderall no i think that's what i heard
no i said does that help no i said you
can add
a lot of roles i'm sure if you did at
all it would probably you know it
doesn't help at all no you're not
focused and running like a banshee no no
just 10 milligrams hey brian i'm down to
stay the night out there
i'm not trying
drive down there yeah yeah we'll meet
y'all down there yeah whatever dude yeah
that's good we'll have a nice dinner the
night before get all carved up oh we got
a carb up yeah bns night yeah anybody
else down to doing here
cat not your thing
kyle's getting filmed casey's in shape
yeah you're in shape casey look at that
bear
you're ready to go bro he's got a tail
piece on him yeah casey he's got some
strong legs
i will say this if you're single there
are so many baddies on those trails i'm
in and you're i knew that would get you
in say no casey's in yep okay i knew
that'd get him in case he's casey he's a
quieter that's why i told mark single
like dude like [ __ ] go up and talk to
one he's like dude we're in the middle
of a race yeah
give the [ __ ] dude
and mars like dude get all wet i'm not
here
get covered in mud then ask her for
advice is mark harley sponsored by man
lion
because he should be yeah and that
should at least come his company should
be man
because he's got a and we sell
maine he does
he should say he should have main butter
mate brian he would have laughed at that
so
mark lost his cat oh god he talked about
it on his podcast haters will say yeah
well he's like five years he's like five
or six he's a cat guy he loves that he's
so good with animals he's amazing love
him for that
so he broke up with his girl right she
kept the cats but the
he would still be responsible for going
over there in the morning walking the
cats who walks cats i don't know so he
goes outside
like they have like a little fence there
to walk the five cats or whatever spider
yep cat's name spider goes you know what
i'm gonna see what's over on the other
side of the fence dips out he goes
missing for how many days i don't know
like five eight calories can't leave you
for a long time cattle leave you yeah
because they're cats and they suck yeah
well yeah because they're not
domesticated they're tame but they're
still wild and when i told mark i
deal
they know for a fact do research i can
take that cat put in my house that cat
doesn't give a flying [ __ ]
they have no emotional they're serial
killers so anyways mark's
all like you know i'm making jokes about
his cat missing yeah he's non-stop
making fun of him meanwhile mark's
really
i didn't realize he's like oh dude
didn't work out for two weeks like
distraught yeah listen this
hired a bloodhound oh you sniff out the
cat sniff out divine and i go mark do me
a favor you hired a lady she was she has
three bloodhounds dude and they go on
they're gonna sniff out the scent and
show us where the cat's at i go mark do
me a favor how much is it or whatever
800 bucks it would take you 800 set it
on fire it's a complete waste of time
lady comes bloodhounds done finally
don't find the cat cat's still missing
cast i go mark please shake out of this
funk it's a cat get over it
he sent us a video on monday
he says video on monday he's crying they
found the cat like across the street in
a bush nobody checked the bushes they
found the cat he's going we finally
we've got fire we've had a spotter his
ex
[Applause]
she [ __ ] found the cat dude
that's good and i go
yeah i go mark
don't ever send me a video crying again
about a cat and then also but also
can you move on now
can you move the [ __ ] off this energy's
been different at the gym he's been so
much yeah
he went missing for two we didn't hear
from for two weeks yeah some people some
people i definitely i don't mean like
i don't mean like videos like from the
cat bro i'm talking
snot bubbles i gotta see that we got
spiders we [ __ ] we found spiders and
then his russian x in the back uh
german german yeah what would i say
russian yeah same [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying
you know he's he's a sensitive guy
that's him after crying finally
because he went through the bushes to
get
all the look at that hair it just
collects all right you know how you can
tell somebody's a good person the way
they treat animals dude you should
[ __ ] see him with a cat oh my god
dude the way he walks though you're
molesting the cat he walks the cat he
grabs them by the their neck and like
what are you doing and then he's like
nose to nose
like wild cats
he loves dogs too he loves dogs just a
[ __ ] weird cat dude you know yeah
you got snot bubbles
listen to him
listen
that's not him right no i don't know
okay
is her talking german
she's on facetime with her mom
listen embark on
listen to mark
he's all we did it
and that cat's hungry yeah yeah that's
all it was yeah it started meowing
because it was just hungry
otherwise it probably would just still
be
chilling oh man that's amazing he's a
sensitive guy
yeah even if i cried no one would ever
know it i wouldn't be saying video
that's why i told god blessings we saw
him in the gym that day ago why would
you send that video i love him oh yeah
because
cause he said i said i would never solve
it
and his ladies crying they love that cat
crying dude
hey they found god move on mark also he
they were talking about hiring like a
[ __ ] oh it's a psychic a psychic or a
medium that talks to animals so i told
marcus to be able to exactly
who did that you know i told him i said
mark rift in my face i said mark send me
a hundred dollars pretend i'm the
psychic i'll pretend i'm talking to
spider and say he's passed on so you
guys get over it
wow he's open to the idea i had a family
member
i'm talking to spider right now he's
doing okay yeah he was attacked by
mountain lion and it was terrible but
i'm fine now yeah i'm in heaven with the
other cats coyotes get them i had a
family
i know people in my
family uh you know whatever it is uh who
uh their cat went missing and they took
some fur from the cat and they sent it
in an envelope to a psychic in north
carolina desperation for for a reading
on where they're just they're stupid huh
so
they're still stupid these are hard for
me to understand
it is tough for me to understand it's
desperation
it's definitely i guess they want their
closure now my dog that's actual mark
call me dude yeah if my dog goes missing
i'll turn the world around yeah like
i'll figure out where yeah for two days
you're turning the world around yeah two
days two days or two days you can get
you can get
you can get real attached to your dog oh
dogs are different than cats yeah your
dog can be dogs differently cats cats
are straight
i never told you this one time this guy
uh we had we did a video of a leopard
killing a dog uh we watched it on oh
yeah we watched on here yeah and this
dude this dude
sent me a [ __ ]
i think it was a dm i can't remember a
long time ago and he said um
he had a dog and you know he's a soldier
in iraq and this dog he was real close
to his dog he was up you know in iraq
and he goes i'm never listening to you
guys again because
you you have no idea what that is and
what that did to me he had to pull the
car over i was like i'm sorry i wrote
him a long thing i was like i'm sorry oh
i'm not oh i'm not oh maybe we don't
need just listening
but i i felt so bad i wrote him a long
thing he never wrote me back
i was like i'm so sorry i i didn't mean
to make it he probably didn't even feel
bad that [ __ ] he just wanted to
reply i think he really some people just
some people are just more sensitive yeah
you know some people just can't take
[ __ ]
but i don't know i i just think like i
love my dog i've had three dogs die on
me from old age but
that's what that's what happens
i'm not gonna keep your dog for 25 years
you know i was gonna die
it's very sad just know that it's it's
about ten years of joy and after that
but also it's a nightmare and but also
be ready for it and also get another dog
and don't yeah see how many dogs are out
there
there are a lot of dudes
it's just funny to hear she knows what
i'm talking about
i love dogs your parents have a dog
right we were just talking about it
did it pass away yeah they passed away
they didn't tell me so i have no idea
when it passed away
and they still haven't told what a great
way to do it though like you don't even
know when to grieve it's like yes the
pad doesn't matter maybe it was two
years ago maybe it's a day ago when was
it you're all good though you don't seem
too choked up about it i i don't know
how to deal with this yeah because he's
like what the
it's gone or he's gone like
i don't even know when he went dude my
dad put down my pitbull he's like man
this thing's leg was limp but he didn't
even tell he even asked me to make the
decision yeah because when i moved to
l.a i left the pit bull with him because
you know a big backyard and i didn't
know what was gonna happen so i left the
dog with him two months in he's like man
yeah [ __ ] jersey's dead man like what
he's like yeah she was limping really
bad particularly vet they said two
thousand dollars to fix this thing we
put her down i'm like i would have gave
you two grand
wish you would have said something
earlier
yeah that's yeah pops is ruthless
cat you think about butters dying um
there was tomorrow i'm not about it yet
but yeah i would start thinking about it
that was your crazy [ __ ] dog chicken
no no that's my dog
did he die no no she's still alive but
she's really out of shape yeah yeah i
left it with my mom my oldest out here
um she is going to be 10 this year okay
people yeah much feed their dogs boy
yeah
yeah mom mom really did that to her he
looks crazy he does
yeah i guess you did you do like a what
are you who are you from what's up
caroline pierce she's the ufc she does
the reporting oh yeah
okay well there we go here you go oh i
didn't know they didn't count
butters is cute as [ __ ] i don't know
what i do if you passed away i think
how long is the acceptable time to
grieve yeah
if you're working here i'll give you a
week
and then you buy another one but that's
a long time also you got to come to work
anyway oh yeah
you missed one three we gotta let you go
what is uh
what is the um
what does that don't have any health
problems or are you okay no he is
perfectly healthy
he's super cute very cute
that is tragic both of my dogs died in a
car from heat exhaustion oh my god
the workers came to my mom's house my
dog's there i was working at lehman
brothers they put the dogs in the car in
july with the windows in new york the
woman who did it was from indonesia she
did just didn't think and my dogs died
immediately
yeah oh and then they called me and told
me i had to leave work because i was
gonna [ __ ] lose it the next day i
come back and my [ __ ] scumbag friends
i i was getting crank calls on my office
phone i go home
my one buddy donnie's like i'm gonna go
get a hot dog anybody want anything else
that's not nice they were scratching at
the [ __ ] cubicle no i love dogs i
know i accidentally love dogs
help me get over they were calling me
going woof i was like oh buddy you know
that's not very nice yeah but it's like
again it was over they sound like
[ __ ] they were but they're great
the same chapel almost killed what no i
accidentally killed my adoptive parents
dog what'd you do you ran over them no
how did you kill them exhaustion
you left them in the car no outside
arizona oh
oh
it was awesome yeah
yeah it's a long story but yeah it's a
terrible death i know oh i felt i felt
so i mean it was
to this day i still feel bad they're
they're like they're fine they're like
over it you know they're like you know
happened was 20 years ago but i feel so
[ __ ] bad would you just left out
there went skateboarding some [ __ ]
something like that you're a kid though
you know kind of dog was it i don't know
like a little [ __ ] yeah it's
like
no like kind of like a butters but a
little bit bigger that's terrible yeah
i know it was it was
it was tough i felt so
now here's the thing my uh my almost
almost i started packing my [ __ ]
that makes sense but my ex and my
daughter they they ride horses you see
and my daughter grew up riding horses so
they look at horses the way i would look
at a dog for sure okay but even more
magical horse people love their horses
yeah
you know for me i look at them as well
like live long they live a long time
forever
and like 40 years yup and if there's a
movie where the horse gets hurt or shot
like in
harder they fall and watch it with my
daughter i love that movie she goes is
the horse gonna get hurt here i go i was
like what no
boom horse could shoot yeah the horse
gets shot and she was like
you know it was a whole thing it was a
whole thing you know like all right
we're way too we're way too [ __ ]
sensitive about this stuff yeah let's
get off dog death
yeah i'll bring it up old memories and
[ __ ] horse death dogs crocodiles
kayakers man the crocodiles and the
kayakers horses are cool they're just
[ __ ] powerful man the horses scare me
oh they scare me and god they got the
biggest dicks yes like where in montana
my son was like dad what is that i'm
like that is a big black dick that
dangles that's the biggest dick you've
ever seen yes and they are strong you're
talking about a thousand pound 1200 oh
dude i made that video making a joke
that my horse got kicked in the neck i
think it was [ __ ] up man oh my girl's
horse kicked my horse in the [ __ ]
neck and it was [ __ ] it was like a
world star well
yeah that what i think was on world star
with that that horse oh mate there's a
horse he just kicks that horse and kills
it yeah oh yeah died in a second i never
get around like i never go to the back
horses ever people die that way all the
time people
like you get kicked in the horse
people who work with horses usually know
at least one person who got kicked in
the head and was never the same or dude
my stepmom grew up on uh like a farm and
stuff her
her friend uh titty got bit by a horse
oh what how
he's just better too did i send you that
picture of my ex when she got her ass
bit by yeah yeah dove had to pull the
car when he was laughing so yeah that's
hilarious
their teeth are really dull and they
[ __ ] bite dude
it's
it [ __ ] you
she leaned over and she said she felt
like somebody she got hit in the ass
like a shotgun like a shotgun that
[ __ ] horse bit her in the ass and she
had the other teeth dude yeah those are
some chompers she had the worst [ __ ]
bruise bruise i've ever seen in my life
wow brian he has the same teeth as that
horse up there
that's just a bad t-shirt
you guys have the same teeth you may
find me i'll i'm getting that in just a
line and i'm gonna have beautiful
whatever time dude
look at that right there bang see that's
just no that's a nibble i'm talking
that's a mule my stepmom's friend got
her [ __ ] tit
yeah i mean bit the [ __ ]
well my mom's horse she used to have
this horse and her horse was next to a
stable of another horse that was real
nasty and her horse
got in a little swivel and got its
tongue bit off by the other horse [ __ ]
yeah
yeah lost it there he is trying to buy
their tit yeah they'll get you man yeah
you don't want to [ __ ] i'll tell you
what we went to montana though there's
so many horses boston just putting his
whole [ __ ] hand in a horse's nose
it's like they know if the kid he didn't
give a [ __ ]
yeah like they just know it was like a
baby and he was all like grabbing his
ears poking his eyes they were cool with
him you see that that vice thing where
they did that thing on the guys who [ __ ]
donkeys
oh dude this [ __ ] dude all the
time i missed our hands best video of
all time but also you talking about uh
the
soldiers when they got the night vision
and they're in like the middle east
there's just some dude [ __ ] sheep and
they're laughing no i haven't seen that
oh it's fantastic bring that up chin
dude soldiers night vision
guy [ __ ] sheep
on youtube or just on wherever was it a
soldier [ __ ] the sheep no no no no no
no usa no dude we're talking middle east
oh okay guys guys i just want to declare
they're lonely it's late at night she
looking all cute soldiers catch
guy [ __ ] sheep with night vision
[Music]
that's pretty [ __ ] uh zero dark 69
goats yes
listen when there are no women around i
guess
same bid click on the one says same
there you go
can you show this on youtube i'll tell
you on the video go back to when it says
same vid
this one where where
the i think let's go this one yeah it's
the same vid yep
yeah that's reddit we should be all
right
um oh where's it
they took it off i'm sure he gets pulled
out probably a guy having sex with the
[ __ ]
isis terrorist god having sex with
donkey it's hilarious and for those
soldiers me such a pleasure man yeah
you're out there i've seen [ __ ]
action
yeah and then you catch your enemy
[ __ ] a horse or a goat
dude how much fun would they have with
this
okay the deployment's not working yeah
i've hit it many times oh you did yeah
it's not working yeah
well you get the idea though yeah yeah
yeah a guy [ __ ] a sheep yeah it's not
great it all happens
it all happens it all happens in the
pursuit of isis
now they're just oh oh oh there's one oh
there it is yeah
look at that night vision dude
now is he riding that thing or is he
just [ __ ] yeah he's [ __ ] that
thing
yeah he's upon it big difference yeah so
do you think that this was legitimately
captured by a drone was it staged was it
fake i bet the sheep is like what in the
[ __ ] have you had sex with a donkey
enemy
yeah
that's what it looks like yeah
for those soldiers by just a real treat
you know yeah it's like christmas you're
gonna yeah i mean it's like all right
what do you got jen
all right
life sucks
yeah when you gotta [ __ ] up yeah right
that's the only friend you have i know
so a while ago we talked about
a story where a little boy got attacked
by a pit bull and he was actually saving
his younger sister from the attack his
name is bridger walker a lot of
marvel superheroes came out and invited
him on to set because he was a huge
marvel fan oh wow he recently went on
set to visit tom holland on the
spider-man 3 set
wow that's so cool man he also says he's
very proud of his scar because it
reminds him of saving his sister that's
good yeah is that that's going to be a
permanent scar probably yeah it got a
lot better though you got a lot better
a little little badass though man were
they out of
um
somewhere in america you know so cute
man look at those two little i know he
kind of has like almost like uh josie
aldo
yeah yeah but aldo's just the chat yeah
just
like yeah a little joker vibe going on
there
a little badass though yep yeah that's a
heavy heavy cute kid man both of her
yeah poor kid
all right next one and this is the
little update to the elon musk story
that we talked about he
sold this
freeloader 14 billion worth of stocks in
tesla and now he is going to be paying
11 billion in taxes this year
we know the rich cover like 89 of all
taxes that's correct right so when you
say the rich don't pay taxes you pay all
the taxes the majority and troy reed
jerry reid who calls him a freeloader
and uh the the dumbest person on tv joy
reid what a [ __ ] so what are they
what are you gonna do it doesn't matter
yeah who cares where did they get this
information that he did that they don't
pay taxes then
uh it's just a cool narrative tax the
rich yeah it's like
yeah and it also doesn't you know it's
like that's that's your answer yeah
she's just though she's i wouldn't
listen her based on the worst she's the
worst
she called him a freeloader she's just
so stupid she's just
they say tax the rich like well they're
already paying ninety percent of our
taxes it's it's so easy to say that
makes sense
yeah you should watch her yeah like
watch i don't want to watch it no [ __ ]
this thank you we can't play it
anyways so this is another really
wholesome story a sixth grader recently
saved one of his classmates from choking
uh he gave his classmate the heimlich
remover heimlich is that maneuver
maneuver there we go now remover
uh but he saved his classmate later that
day he actually helped a disabled woman
who was caught in a burning fire out of
the home
so he got a special award dedicated to
him and his mother said that he actually
wants to be at emt really badly he
always wanted to help people damn little
stud man right all in the same day
that's cool
because batman looks like he could be my
son i would you know i don't want to say
anything but thank you
probably in your future
you weren't always a thick boy though no
jabel's vegan dude you are vegan now
about 99.98 how's your energy thickest
vegan
well when you're vegan a lot of times
your your carb
intake is going to be going up it
depends how you do it because you've got
to be careful we've got some boys who
are vegan or monsters yeah it's hard to
do it but it's ooh you got you you know
i'm saying we like totally yeah i'm not
against it dan smith uh yeah [ __ ] uh
travis barkley best cardio i know yeah
i'm not against it if you know how to do
it but you got to be those people like
travis barker guys like that know they
do it you know really science yeah toby
he's been vegan since like 80 89 88 yeah
i think i think sometimes there's a
tendency to
your your carb intake goes higher goes
higher yeah which is fair yeah so you
see like a lot of like and a lot of
people do it for the wrong reasons a lot
of people try to do it because they
think oh i'll lose weight
if it's like you know you can learn
you're eating a lot of lentils yeah
that's sort of like you could eat bad as
a yes yeah yeah
yeah i'm drunk right now the people that
i've the diet the healthiest people that
i've seen
tend to be people who eat
like most of their protein comes from
fish shellfish and vegetables like they
tend to be kind of paleo
for the most part those are the people
that i find do you eat a lot of
crossfitters that i know
it's true
it's true they tend to be healthier if
you eat if your carbs come from
primarily vegetables and not breads and
things like that i i just
and and you know if you do i'm a
pescetarian you hear people say that
those are the people that i usually like
their skin
they their energy they're skinny no
matter what though you know not skinny
muscular yeah some of them yeah but
those are the people
you know they're on the other stuff yeah
you know that yeah
why yeah
why i was trying to listen to your
explanation but i'm not talking about
the pros i'm just talking about people
that i've seen that are
i would imagine like i feel like
mediterranean diet that's how they eat
yeah pretty much vegetables
seafood lean meats yeah ethiopians too
right i feel beef's not bad
beef's not bad it's like steaks not bad
no no no chicken do you eat a lot of red
meat i don't i can't i didn't think you
did don't break it down as well yeah but
i'll have a steak periodically and i
like it
and if i if i stick to eating
like i do really well with chicken and
seafood as a protein and then i do
really well with just like vegetables
but if i eat broccoli and stuff like
that i get all right
you fart yeah bart fart central
so you know if i if i'm i eat red meat
chick-fil-a
stronger than everybody in here yeah you
know close that was the ordering chicken
tonight and all those people yeah that's
cool what else you got jen hey hey what
the [ __ ] dude you take it easy i don't
care what your friends eat you know hey
bro i don't know them you know you're
always dieting you're always doing a new
diet nah not really yeah you are not
really not because at nighttime
you roll out he breaks out the whiskey i
won't train for tough mudder he'll beat
all you guys whatever your friends or
whatever uh what do you got yeah
yeah okay so everyone already knows
haran woody got knocked out pretty bad
by jake paul yeah and then someone
actually made a meme of him and it was
so good that tyron woodley put it on his
page and paid the guy five thousand
dollars
wow why would he pay the guy five
thousand dollars for the picture it was
just a really well done meme i wonder if
oh
he bought the rights to it so he could
make an nft of it later
what's the check it out
oh hold up
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah and then this is the proof of uh
hold up
there did
he said 5000 like you owed it or just
because the guy made it i don't know why
he did it maybe because he just thought
it was it was just really well done so
he's like i'm gonna give you 5k
what else you got jen
you hear me or guys [ __ ] cheap huh
nothing what else you got
um
let's go with this another feel good
story this girl saved someone in the
drive-through lane from choking on a
chicken mcnugget that dude that's the
heimlich chicken nuggets yeah those get
dicey done she she's autistic too she's
10 years old autistic she's 10 i think
i'm pretty sure she is not 10 yeah
15 15 close enough well
and doesn't she kind of look like um not
a 10 year old chef shanko
oh no a little bit yeah she's got a
little uh valentina
yeah and she was awarded 100 bucks for
it she jumped out of the drive through
window
to save this person yeah
the police station the guy just got five
thousand for a [ __ ] vehicle all that
money yeah right they're gonna give her
a hundred dollars i think tom probably
made a call going to the vault for that
one mcdonald's yeah
you have people [ __ ] setting up like
oh i was joking somebody jumps out i
helped did you know what i someone told
me uh
come out and show how they made their
mcnuggets because that rumor went so
viral
that's gross because it is kind of like
it's all white i promise
yeah i mean i'll chomp on that [ __ ]
yeah but they're delicious i love them
they are dude in the sweet and sour they
are fresh right
casey brought a whole bunch of them for
thanksgiving you know what i ate a ton
of those we ate all of them
that's right casey ate a ton of them
they're nice
they don't beat [ __ ] chick-fil-a
nuggets
right now dude we had a family pack of
30 last night with the kids
oh they love they're really good oh it's
all white meat like actual meat yeah
like like mcdonald's never looks like me
no it doesn't like that
[ __ ] you but so you're saying the uh the
you're the family
real it's real oh real meat dude real
chicken tough to beat chick-fil-a and
they're waffle fries
[ __ ]
you know this actually reminds me when i
was in elementary school this is just
messed up this is how kids are but our
teacher had a call you know that phone's
inside the rooms get a call during class
and he's like freaking out and he's
telling us oh [ __ ] he cussed too he goes
my wife just slipped on a chicken nugget
and i dropped our kid but all the kids
you just slipped on a chicken nugget
that's what we're hearing yeah it's
funny yeah but then when the kids are
just laughing he's like how dare you
guys here
i don't know
just so
what happened to the kid
he said that kid so she slipped and the
kid probably hit his head in the back of
a table so it was really really bad but
he was okay i don't know
i don't know you never got you never got
a full story yeah yeah what's the
chicken i don't know some people tell
you stories like where it just ends it's
like this guy's like and uh these drug
cartels were in a shootout and this kid
was a great piano player amazing
nintendo it was just award-winning and
the bullet hit him and the kid went
paralyzed and
i was like there's nowhere to go with it
but the kid's okay now yeah
maybe no we don't know man he's not
doing great well that's it don't tell me
those things yes don't tell me those
stories are tough i don't know are they
just in right there oh look at this
it's just the video's too long but this
is basically steven a smith going off on
kyrie irving my favorite stephen a smith
me like i have a huge announcement to me
i think everybody should know this
i got coach that's covered everyone's
all you're so brave oh join the [ __ ]
everybody gets covered you got covered
then you went until the rant so it was
just like here's covenant
everyone i know i know
after the discussion with our coach
player staff the organization has
decided to have kyrie irving uh
rejoining the team for games practices
which she's able to participate so he
can't play in new york yeah
we arrived at the decision with the full
support of our players that's because
he's such a good [ __ ] player they
need him to win a championship
uh we look forward to kyrie's return the
lineup as well as getting our entire
roster back together all right yep and
then where then we got steven a smith
yeah but this is a long ride are they
doing really good this season brooklyn
it's still early but yeah they're good
and the audio on that's really really
bad he says the disgraceful move by the
met because he's on that bike bringing
him back because he's on vaccinated
i mean i mean all right how about the
white house message anybody oh they said
anybody who's vaccinated enjoy your
holiday we're gonna get through this you
unvaccinated enjoy your seeing your
family and yourself die yeah
what
holy [ __ ] bite it unbelievable
i think uh steven's rant was more like
what you guys are saying how kyrie if
kyra really wanted to be a part of the
team or really wanted to play then he
would have grown yeah like jordan oh
that's all he's pretty much
kyrie doesn't play bad enough
he's just such a talent they're gonna
put up with it yeah all right so kurt
warner wore this jacket and it's been
it's getting less he's getting mocked
like crazy over there's a movie coming
out what's wrong with that jacket it's
just i don't know but then the these are
cool these are actually pretty funny
that's hilarious why did he wear the
other jiffy pop thing here
of course george costanza
lady gaga
i don't know what this is what the hell
is that it's looking good he's might
have had some work done his face looks
tough
doesn't his face look even the nfl
network got into it
does his face look extra shiny yeah for
sure yeah
he looks like more feminine too i think
this is pretty good too interesting
he's had things he's that oh they made
him smooth over he's added smooth over
maybe some fillers everyone's clowning
everyone his eyebrows are a little
what's he thinking i'm going to make a
call right now i think he had himself a
little brother we'll get some more he
has some botox
yeah there's not a wrinkle on his
[ __ ] sprinkle on his face he looks
good though yeah chipotle actually
really does he can do whatever he wants
he's a stud
isn't he the first guy to ever come from
like afl yeah wow
and when a super bowl b mvp he was a
stud man yeah he was
what are you guys
this guy kent state lyman he puked and i
guess because of that it was called he
was flagged for a false start oh that's
stupid
i'll show you right here
maybe he's really sick oh damn they
called that a false start he didn't
[ __ ] he didn't even move
i think for the other side or something
i forgot what it was
he must have been super sick
yep
well
and that's pretty much it well this was
kind of cool there was this like long
high speed chase with this guy that
stole a fire truck and suddenly a
homeless man got in front of it
for like 20 minutes talked to the guy
and the guy got out oh wow the other
homeless guy surrendered peacefully
tried to maneuver around that man but
witnesses say he was eventually
convinced to surrender peacefully
like he's
all there good for him man steal a
[ __ ]
fire truck yeah i've always wanted to do
it yeah i'm gonna do it
like some people just decide to take the
cops on a chase they're like i could
stop you know it's weird you know i'm
gonna give you that's where to me
whenever there's a high speed chase and
like the 405 or 101 they literally
stop everything and record it all yeah
it could be two hours dude yeah him just
driving through the neighborhoods so my
body never happened my buddies never
knew his father and then later on
connected with his father when he was
much older and his father was just this
mercenary this dude who had like
gone to the french foreign legion you
know you know that that's just was in
wars and just kind of a rough dude right
and my buddy's kind of rough guy so he's
like that's interesting so he talked to
his mom and he said so what happened
with you guys and she goes well
um
he and his friend came running into the
house i was pregnant with you they came
running into the house and they
pulled out their guns and boarded up the
[ __ ] windows
and they go we just robbed a bank and
they were being chased
and she was like
what and they're waiting for the cops
you can hear the sirens and then
three days later nothing happens and he
goes
just kidding i was just [ __ ] around
with you
and
starts pulling up and she was like i'm
the [ __ ] out of here we'll see you later
and that was again that was good
yeah that's crazy that's his dad
do you have any other details that we
don't care about
you know this terrible story yeah i
couldn't wait for that to end do you
believe that story no not at all his dad
wasn't didn't do any of that but
i just wanted to end first of all why
would she leave yeah why was she going
out or something you know i just felt
like i did because no one knows who he
is either well i just felt like some
people decide to do something crazy and
they and then that guy did crazy stuff
and that guy didn't know his dad
well all right fine i guess i won't tell
you any more bank robber stories what is
this now you guys were talking about
people filming
so oh you saw this too people filming so
this cop for some reason got into an
altercation with one of the guys at the
airport i think that was canceled or
something like that so then the cop
pulls out a gun and then people
literally in this in the line of you
know
they're just doing this yeah
filming it yeah dummies all these people
you'll see in a second so is the cop
doing choking them you get right yeah
all these people are like trying to like
cop the cops the guy's actually trying
to punch the cop too which is stupid
what if that kid knows how this ends for
him
so watch here he pulls out a gun oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
oh all these people get the [ __ ] kid
out of it look at all the phones
also what's that guy doing with that
footage look how stupid these people are
like who that little boy
[Applause]
why are so many people yelling i don't
know
you need backup dude
he was calling back up back up he was
calling down big top man
that are out of shape are insane there's
so many though dude i know they're all a
lot of them
some are in crazy shape and then some
are just so awesome well florida you see
something like dude you pull me over i'm
running dude
they'll just have their bulletproof vest
on and basically just a tank top over i
mean they they're pretty much they'll
have their guns strapped to their leg
they look rough who are these guys
alberto
yanez juarez
these guys got arrested
his eyes are very bloodshot it looks
like it got sprayed or something
does look like you got sprayed yeah or
crying okay he looks like mark after
finding the cat
that's itching that's it that's it
all right kids uh we got a show tonight
hollywood improv sold out brent shop and
friends at the hollywood improv don't
worry if you didn't get tickets we got a
bunch more shows coming up uh at the
hollywood improv shop and friends in
january and february so i'll release
those tickets soon and then dania
florida fort lauderdale florida december
30 through january 1st then rally north
carolina's january 6th through the 8th
raleigh
january 6th through january 8th pick us
at f-a-t-k-z dot com briar
uh daddy's going to be in oklahoma city
oklahoma bricktown comedy club then salt
lake city utah wise guys january 6 7 8.
i had to reschedule spokane washington
spokane
spokane whatever it is spokane uh
january 20th 21st 22nd i will not be
there you have to reschedule because we
got a fight companion the 22nd with
christa stefano crystalia myself and you
february 25th through the 26th i'll be
at the comedy club of kansas city boom
and then tonight and then i'll be with
brendan in january and this is
chappelle's merch i'm rocking yeah and
then brenda's also i like your first
dude
i'm your model yeah you [ __ ] good i'm
your model dude
yeah now you give me an xl i know you
know i need a double yeah i got you it's
time for my body
that is a uh you need a devil xl he
needs a double salve has some tint yeah
your head that shows off your outfit
yeah the self wants knowledge shows your
altitude
this elf wants some eggnog
i'm going to suck it out of you oh no
all right we're out of here